hunger and hopelessness are driving
Lebanese to the streets the economy is
close to collapsing protesters vent
their anger at banks for preventing
people from accessing their savings and
the long-serving political elite is
being blamed for mismanagement and
corruption in recent days the local
currency has sharply devalued against
the dollar there were casualties among
protesters and soldiers during
confrontations that began Monday night
people went to the streets because there
are no jobs children are asking the
parents for food and that don't have
money to buy them any the young man who
is martyred was a father he had nothing
to lose if his daughter asked for food
what will he give up he had nothing to
lose calls for a change in leadership
are not new a protest movement began in
October but the ruling elite has clung
on to power apart from a few we have a
hundred and twenty eight criminals in
parliament they stole public funds and
transferred billions of dollars outside
Lebanon even the army soldier is
oppressed like us their salary is now
worth three hundred dollars officials
acknowledge inflation has increased by
fifty percent and forty five percent of
a nation of six million people live
below the poverty line but they haven't
presented any plan to restore trust in
the economy and fight corruption we are
hungry the revolution is against
corruption all officials say there's
corruption but what have they done we
don't see any thief in prison instead
they are shooting at the people rival
politicians who have been in power for
decades deny allegations of corruption
and are blaming each other for the
states near bankruptcy government
leaders are accusing their opponents of
trying
to topple them by tampering with
financial stability that fuels the anger
of anti-government protesters the
leadership's opponents say those in
power are trying to hold them
accountable for years of corruption the
state's finances are under immense
pressure Lebanon has a huge debt to pay
and not enough foreign currency the
government also doesn't have many
friends abroad these scenes could be a
warning of what's to come XANA cutter al
jazeera Tripoli well as a mentioned
there Lebanon's economy has been in
freefall for months now with jobs in
short supply and the government
struggling under massive debt over the
past week the currency has rapidly lost
its value of forcing the central bank to
set an exchange rate of one u.s. dollar
for 3,200 Lebanese pounds the government
is in talks with the International
Monetary Fund over a bailout the
five-year proposal aims to boost growth
to 2 percent by 2024 and requires some
10 to 15 billion dollars the money is
desperately needed with the IMF
forecasting Lebanon's economy shrinking
by 12 percent this year Rami Khouri is a
senior public policy fellow and
journalism professor at the American
University of Beirut he joins us now
live via Skype from Beirut good to have
you with us again
Rami it seems like right it was just a
few months ago you and I were sitting
here talking about protests in in Beirut
what do you make of what's going on in
Tripoli today it's very predictable this
was clear about a year ago that the
economy was gradually collapsing because
the central bank simply could not
maintain the levels of foreign exchange
that were needed to run the economy that
created a lot of lack of confidence in
the banks depositors were not able to
take most of their money out of the bank
starting about four or five months ago
the people lost their jobs people would
not lend very much to anybody there was
no real investment in productive
industry so the whole chain reaction
happened and though the worst part of it
now and what you're seeing on the
streets in Tripoli and and Beirut
Seiden and the south and other places
are desperate people really desperate
the young people who don't have a job we
don't have money don't have savings
don't have any social protection
insurance the government can't help them
out and they're they're desperate there
and their slogan is we're hungry we're
hungry and this was very predictable
it's really a sign of financial
mismanagement and political poor poor
governments who's to blame though you
say it's it's political mismanagement
and poor governance understandably
people are angry to what extent do they
only have themselves to blame though
well the blame goes really to everybody
the central bank was the central actor
in this financial engineering scheme
which some economists have called the
Ponzi scheme which eventually ran out of
steam and couldn't be maintained the
banks themselves were very complicit
they were making huge amounts of
interest on loans that they were giving
the central bank the central bank was
taking their money financing the
government spending a huge government
deficit year after year with a lot of
corruption as well and depositors who
were putting their money in the banks
were also making a lot of interest so
that's why this went on for so many
years
everybody was benefitting and people
thought it would go on forever but like
most illusory Ponzi schemes it doesn't
go on forever at some point it collapses
the smart people got their money out
early and most of the people didn't and
though there's huge suffering the
poverty in Lebanon is now probably over
50% inequality is rising unemployment as
there's a - 250,000 people possibly have
been unemployed in the last few months
it's just a huge economic implosion and
the government has been very very slow
to address it they're supposed to meet
tomorrow to finalize a package of
decisions and it's still gonna take you
months to actually get things moving if
they do move yeah how does Lebanon
extricate itself from this mess and and
will people tolerate the fix
people will tolerate the fix if it is a
serious one that promises ending
corruption retrieving billions and
billions of stolen money and corrupt
money and giving a promise that the
economy will get back to some kind of
even keel it's it's a problem that many
countries have had Greece had it Cyprus
had it when as well as we're not the
first country to go through this all you
have to do is re-establish confidence in
the banking system get investors to
start investing in productive industries
produce economic wealth that you then
spend and and the economic cycle then
goes into positive instead of negative
this requires probably 15 to 20 billion
dollars of foreign grants and loans and
investments which which will come if
there is that critical change which
requires serious credible non-corrupt
accountable governance and this is one
of the things that Lebanon has lacked
really good tortilla rummy many thanks
indeed Rami Khouri there professor of
journalism at the American University of
Beirut